but we we talked about your love of LA
Dodgers last time and I heard that when
you went there I am wearing Roger blue
the beginning of the season but so the
last time you were there Billie Jean
King was there and you got to hang out
yeah I had seats that were way far away
from the field and somehow somebody in
the Dodger World said you know there's
some empty seats you can come on down
and the seats were like Billie Jean King
was right here
so I'm trying to act natural
um and it was a day and it was a big
setback for Roe v Wade so to me the it
was so meaningful to get to meet and
thank this person who has been working
for women's freedom and Independence for
her whole life that I got to actually
say yeah thank you yeah that's I didn't
even think about it like that that day
it was the day that one of the big you
know backslides occurred so at least I
had someone to be grateful for and then
she went onto the field which I think
she does every game she was like come on
really so I got to meet Dave Roberts oh
my gosh it's on my Instagram actually
you see me meeting him and I have a
smile that's like from here to here and
if you look carefully I just keep saying
over and over I'm so happy happy I'm so
happy I had so my I didn't I didn't grow
up in a ton of stores but I I loved
Nolan Ryan growing up because yeah Texas
girl yeah yeah yeah and I met Nolan Ryan
oh my God and I had the same grit it was
just like a childhood thing and he
signed a baseball it's different even
than meeting entertainers it is because
it's out of your world right yeah like
how could they do what they how do you
know when Ryan throw it that way it's
incredible yeah so I get this smile from
here I looked ridiculous but I was happy
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]